[ __ ] there for your last year
dachshund motto more than 40 years ago
nigerian music legend Fela Kuti San go
slow that's now the name for traffic
jams in Lagos
almost 20 million people live in the
mega city so go slow's are normal on its
streets that doesn't bother Charles
afiya the IT consultant works while he's
in transit a small Wi-Fi modem in the
car makes it possible check my emails
first for i charged my clans last time I
do video calls also yes type and change
my life not just my life my business
also because I'm always Molly's touching
my clients in June the Metro taxi
company equipped part of its fleet with
internet modems cab driver segun babosa
says passengers are enthusiastic when
the web has not been inside the vehicle
people tells you you have to hurry up do
this complain about this and that but
now they are concentrating with what
they are doing with the internet
wherever so we don't have much of a
discussion with their clients only be
concentrating all around my own driving
where they also concentrate doing what
they are doing with their own internet
his boss priscilla ebay coordinates the
taxis they're stiff competition in the
taxi sector free Wi-Fi has expanded
metros customer base
yes it's the future of taxi business
Legos doesn't sleep so we are online
twenty-four-seven so yes we are trends
where trendsetter yes aspect or firm
internet usage llegas is a booming
metropolis more and more people are
moving here they welcomed innovations
like Wi-Fi in taxis the experiment does
involve a certain amount of risk high
speed Wi-Fi doesn't come cheap so segun
the taxi driver always keeps an eye on
his passengers to keep costs down what
you themes is not allowed which I mixed
clay to some of my friends I have please
he's not permitted to go on YouTube
downloading and others are on that kind
of thing you know we are some young
young girls guys that might make does a
little day they are so interested but
most regular customers are traveling on
business they use the free internet
connection to get work done Charles
ophea values the company service because
he certainly can't speed up that slow
trip to the office
chief says smart idea